SAL KHAN: I'm here with our
exercise guru, Ben Eater--
BEN EATER: Hi, Sal.
SAL KHAN: --who made this
exercise, and now we're
going to try to work through it.
So let's see.
It says what are
the factors of 9?
You can re-size this box
with 9 dots-- the box
has 9 dots-- to help
you find the factors.
BEN EATER: So what
you're looking at,
is you've got these
9 dots on the screen.
And right now, there are
just 1 row of 9 dots.
And if you grab
that little thing
on the right side of the box and
move that around to the left--
SAL KHAN: Oh, that's neat.
BEN EATER: --you
still have 9 dots,
but they're arranged
differently.
SAL KHAN: I see.
BEN EATER: And so what you
can see is, try to get them
so you have the same
number in each row.
SAL KHAN: I see, so this one.
So if you have-- let's
see, not the same number.
BEN EATER: There you go.
SAL KHAN: Oh, 3 there.
And so you could get
to 9 by literally
multiplying 3 rows
times 3 columns.
BEN EATER: That's right.
SAL KHAN: And you get to 9.
BEN EATER: So 3 is a factor.
SAL KHAN: And then we would
write that in this box right
over here.
BEN EATER: Mm-hm.
SAL KHAN: So we'd write 3--
do we have to write 3 twice,
because we have-- or is
just writing 3 once--
BEN EATER: 3 is the factor--
SAL KHAN: 3 is a factor.
BEN EATER: --so you
just put it once.
SAL KHAN: We don't
have to write it.
If we wrote it twice
would it be wrong?
BEN EATER: Uh-huh,
yes, actually.
SAL KHAN: It would?
OK, so--
BEN EATER: We do
mark that wrong.
SAL KHAN: --you actually
do mark that wrong.
OK, so there's 3 and 3.
But there was also, right when
you started, you had 9 and 1.
BEN EATER: That's right.
Both of those are factors.
SAL KHAN: And I
don't have to write
these in any special order?
BEN EATER: No, no.
SAL KHAN: 1 and 9.
BEN EATER: Just got
to get them all.
SAL KHAN: And I believe
that's all there is.
And we could look
at the other ones,
and we can see, look
2 and 8 definitely--
BEN EATER: No.
SAL KHAN: No, that's
not working out.
It's interesting
for people to think
about why these
aren't working out.
BEN EATER: Right.
Yeah, you can't divide 2 into 9.
SAL KHAN: And this just
gets us to 1 and 9 again,
and we don't want to repeat it.
BEN EATER: Those are
the same factors.
SAL KHAN: Exactly.
So let's check our answer.
Let's see how we're doing.
BEN EATER: OK.
SAL KHAN: Let's see.
There we go.
We got it all right.
Let's do one more.
BEN EATER: OK.
SAL KHAN: Let's do one more.
Correct.
The next question.
You can resize this
box with 16 dots
to help you find the factor.
It's 1 and 16.
BEN EATER: 1 and 16
are factors, sure.
SAL KHAN: So me write those.
BEN EATER: Those
are all its factors.
SAL KHAN: So 1 and 16.
So let's play with
this box here.
That's not working.
So I'm trying to figure
out-- so this is essentially
going 2 times-- 2 might be
a factor if I could just--
oh look, it is.
BEN EATER: There it is, yeah.
2 is a factor
SAL KHAN: 2 is a factor.
BEN EATER: And so is 8.
SAL KHAN: Exactly, exactly.
2 rows of 8 works.
And so we could say
2 and 8 are factors.
BEN EATER: And if
you think about it,
2 and 8 both divide into 16.
SAL KHAN: Absolutely.
BEN EATER: 2
divides eight times.
SAL KHAN: Yes.
BEN EATER: Or 8
divides two times.
SAL KHAN: Yes, you can that.
You can construct.
BEN EATER: Right.
SAL KHAN: 16 dots, you can
divide them into 2 groups of 8.
BEN EATER: That's right.
SAL KHAN: And I suspect
also 8 groups of 2.
BEN EATER: Well,
you can see that.
SAL KHAN: Let's see,
so that's 2 groups
of 8, really, or 2 rows of 8.
Let's see, or oh, look at that.
4 times 4.
BEN EATER: 4 times 4.
SAL KHAN: And I'll
just write the 4 once.
BEN EATER: So 4 is a factor.
SAL KHAN: 4 is a factor.
And then I can-- and I've
probably-- well, I've
already gotten 8 and 2.
BEN EATER: Already got that.
SAL KHAN: Now I have 8 groups
of 2 instead of 2 groups of 8,
but they're still both factors.
Then you go back to 16 and 1.
BEN EATER: That's right.
SAL KHAN: So I think we're done.
BEN EATER: I think so.
SAL KHAN: Let's
check our answer.
Oh--
BEN EATER: Very good.
SAL KHAN: --very
good, very good.
Well, thank you.
That was fun.
BEN EATER: Thank you.
SAL KHAN: This was very
neat, very fun to play with.
BEN EATER: Well, thanks.